folks my uncle Larry is in the audience
tonight and he loves this bit so I'd
love to invite him up on stage if he
doesn't mind yeah show me sure
so uncle Larry is uh visiting from
Boston how's it your meeting is that bad
I wish you would yeah
so the Lariat uncle is that better yeah
as as good as it gonna get this is my
wonderful uncle Larry he's currently
going through chemotherapy for bone
cancer
he loves this bit so we thought we would
do a very special wash madamn tales with
you if that's okay
final me great everyone uh hey cancer
that's right cancer yeah you uninvited
you make people feel bad make
them go through chemotherapy and you try
and crush their spirits making nauseous
we said hell nah
we got our family we got our friends and
we're gonna with or without you have a
happy life so how about this
get out of my uncle go yourself
wash my damn towels